well in a moment I'll speak to Megan's
half-brother Thomas Jr exclusively
here's a short reminder of what Megan
Harry said about her father in the show
including a series of supposedly private
messages she sent to him when it emerged
he was too ill to attend their wedding
perhaps in journalist immediately
following him all day every day the
unraveling happened that week when he
wouldn't pick up my call
and instead you're talking to TMZ he had
a heart attack six days ago which is
crazy calling calling calling calling
this is not him saying oh I don't want
to be there mama I get it and the world
is watching this drama
of course it's incredibly sad what
happened she had a father before this
and now she doesn't have a father
well joining me now is Megan's
half-brother Thomas Morgan Thomas thank
you for joining me um first of all uh
how is your father Thomas senior
oh hey guys it's good to be here
um dad is doing very well uh making a
lot of progress he's in good spirits
um sometimes he doesn't feel that
comfortable to actually make a live
appearance but uh he's doing very well
you're there caring for him he had a
massive stroke and I think at one stage
for quite a while he lost the power of
his speech has that returned now is he
able to communicate with you
yeah his uh his speeches is definitely
coming back we're making a lot of
progress with the speech therapy and and
you know if for the most part it's it's
pretty normal it just it goes off after
a few moments but comes back so it's
he's doing very well I'm I'm just very
happy that I could be here every day for
him since since this happened in May or
or what about six months ago were you
both watching the the first half of this
series today
uh let's see I think I think he was he
wasn't able to join us though I mean he
really wanted to be here
um I was watching it and you know I'm
just glad I had my studio magic tear pen
with me so I could have a tear come out
of my left eye while I was watching it I
mean that moment when Prince Harry has
never met your father says that Megan
has no father
what did you think of that
I think it's horrible
um the documentary is so far off on so
many different levels so many it's just
it really is really a little bit
disturbing
um
saying that you know she doesn't have a
family and she doesn't have a father and
then Harry's saying that uh you know she
has no father now that's just ridiculous
yeah I mean it's incredibly hurtful I
also have always had sympathy with your
father because I felt that he was thrown
to the wolves with no experience of
dealing with this kind of media
intensive media attention he tried to do
the right thing he came unstuck and they
just disowned him
um has she made any attempt to contact
your father since he had his stroke
none whatsoever and you know I totally
agree with you on on the fact that none
of us were ever coached or given any
help with the paparazzi or press since
the very beginning which has caused a
lot of problems
um
nobody reached out I actually reached
out and and all I got back was distant
family and she doesn't know us which is
just you know it's just very bizarre
how she just basically brushed the
entire family under the carpet like we
don't exist and then lied about not
having a family and lied about you know
she doesn't have a family that she's
always wanted you know we've always been
here it's
documentaries way off I mean that's
that's what's actually prompted me to
work with my own production team
um and coming out in like 2023 we're
gonna have you know our side of the doc
our side of a documentary that's going
to shed a lot of light well I don't
blame you I mean
this is one of my family doing this to
my family I want to do the same thing
and set the record straight it seems to
me that she's decided you're all too big
a problem therefore you have to be cut
loose and I gotta be honest I I knew
Megan for a bit before she met Harry did
exactly the same to me bang you know
done she did that to many people that
she knew that she'd either worked with
or was friends with or whatever it just
seems to me she's what I would call a
ruthless social climber who just when
people are no longer yeah you know no
longer appropriate parts of her Circle
they have to be expunged quickly so she
can move on up a ladder
absolutely and I think a lot of greed
plays into that fact also I mean the
amount of unprecedented files photos
videos and documentation that that we're
going to be including in our documentary
it's going to tell a whole different
story and I think the the I think the
general public and the UK and America
knows
that now the markers aren't bad people
we're we're just like a normal family
like everybody else we do exist and when
when one person tells lies and then
tells 10 other lies to cover the one lie
and it keeps on going you know this is
what happens you you end up looking
ridiculous there's a staggering moment
Thomas where
um Ashley who is I think your niece
who's Samantha's daughter uh befriended
Megan and was gonna go to the wedding
and then Megan is apparently advised by
some funky at the palace that wouldn't
be a good idea because Samantha's not
invited so this happens
how do we explain that this half-sister
isn't invited to the wedding but that
the half-sister's daughter is
and so
with Ashley the guidance at the time was
to not have her come to our wedding
I think I said I was
hurt on some level but I understood
where it was coming from
to know that it was because of my
biological mother that
this relationship that's so important to
me
was impacted in that way
[Music]
I feel like because of her was taken
away
has been hard
yeah actually it was because of Megan
that it was taken away Megan could have
had her there as she wanted to have it
there instead she wanted to have a bunch
of celebrities she barely knew from the
cloonies to the beckhams to Elton John
to James Gordon to Timbuktu I mean he
looked like anyone she'd met on the
party circuit in the previous two years
got the invite but a lot of Harry's
friends weren't there and nor was this
niece who she makes a big thing in the
documentary saying we were so close
yeah well I mean there you have it you
know one lie turns into 20 other lies
she didn't have a family so therefore
nobody was invited
I mean
I mean who doesn't invite their family
to a wedding especially a royal wedding
and it's not like it's not like anybody
in my family asked her for one nickel or
anything ever we were all actually like
happy for her when all this happened but
the slow turn of events showed the true
colors of this woman when you when you
finish watching today these first three
episodes what was it kind of overview
about what's happened to to Megan and
indeed what do you think of Harry
well my general overview is I can't
believe
that she was able to be in this position
all by my father's doing by the way
to be in that position and to know what
you're getting yourself into
and then go in there and try and change
a thousand-year-old tradition and
monarchy to to your own liking
who does that
um
it's it's still it's still a big
question I mean my father and I we talk
about it quite a bit it's like I mean
how could you even even consider doing
that you were
everything every woman in their life
could ever dream of you had and you had
to go and make waves and accusations and
be difficult and overall you know taking
Harry away from his family right yeah
I'm afraid I think he's completely
described like I said
um Thomas I gotta leave it there thank
you very much indeed for joining me
please send your father my best weren't
you because I've been concerned about
him
um I'm glad to hear he's he's on the
mend absolutely obviously been a scary
time for you and the family please send
him my very best
absolutely will do thank you so much for
having me all right good to talk to you